MANDIP WARAICH: Hello,
everyone, and welcome.
My name is Mandip
Waraich, and I'm
the head of product
for industrial AI
in Google's cloud business.
I lead a portfolio of
artificial intelligence products
that help solve some of
the most complex and hard
industrial problems
at global scale.
Today I'm going to talk
about three things.
First, the current
state of automation
and industrial efficiency and
how artificial intelligence is
revealing an entirely new
universe of possibilities.
Second, Google Cloud's
approach to bringing these AI
technologies to the market.
And third, our deploy
methodology that helps
achieve the impact of AI at
a global enterprise scale.
Let me first begin by sharing
how we are approaching
our strategy to help industrial
enterprise customers transform
themselves.
So our strategy hinges
on three pillars.
First, is to provide
tools and technologies
to connect your physical assets
and workforce to the cloud.
Second, is to bring both
your existing analytics
tools and new analytics
capabilities that
augment human decision making.
And third, to drive
end to end automation
of key industrial processes by
embedding our differentiated AI
technologies into the
industrial workflows.
As part of this session
I will focus only
on our AI capabilities.
We are applying AI to help
some of the largest enterprise
companies transform
their businesses.
We're helping the largest
airlines better plan
their schedules,
aircraft utilization,
and manage unforeseen
operational disruptions.
We're helping logistic
companies achieve better fleet
utilization, route
planning, and maximize
the life of their assets.
We're helping automotive
companies bring their vehicle
telemetry data to the cloud
and prevent component failure
and recalls in real time.
We'll be discussing two
manufacturing focused
solutions, adaptive controls
and visual inspection,
in more detail in the session.
Here are some of
the companies that
are trusting Google to transform
their industrial operations
and businesses using AI and
machine learning technologies.
Before I get into the
details of AI technologies,
I want to take a
brief talk about where
we are in the broader
industrial automation evolution.
For decades, advances in
automated controls and systems
have made industrial processes
and supply chains highly
efficient, but every subsequent
advance in efficiency
has demanded greater investment
while yielding leaner returns
to a point of
flattening of the curve.
The staggering complexity of
the industrial environment
is now combined with a dynamic
and uncertain environment
like the one we're finding
ourselves right now, where
there's dramatic volatility
in market forces, disrupted
supply chains and
retail channels,
uncertainty of demand, and
cost pressures to stay afloat.
The current industrial
systems are turning out
too brittle and unadaptable,
narrow in their search
for efficiency gains with
years of systemized rules
and heuristics, layers
of operational buffers,
and inefficiencies capped and
accrued by human expertise.
These constraints make
industrial systems
a great candidate for AI machine
learning based solutions.
For machine learning
based systems,
each layer of complexity
is another dimension
to explore for
hidden correlations,
allowing every aspect of
an industrial environment
to be analyzed minutely,
temporally, and [INAUDIBLE],,
individually, and holistically,
exploring new action spaces
and uncovering unfound
efficiency gains.
These systems can adapt to
internal and external headwinds
and learn to anticipate
disruptions, allowing
stable autonomous operation.
We'll talk through two
such examples of autonomous
controls technology, adaptive
controls and visual inspection
AI, both aimed at achieving
autonomous process controls
in industrial facilities.
Let's first talk about
Industrial Adaptive Controls
platform that
automates and optimizes
closed loop industrial systems
like near track systems
or scaled up control
processing plants.
This platform builds on
years of Google's research
in reinforcement learning, where
an AI agent learns directly
from sensory experience
and develops new knowledge
by exploring the action space
and then optimizes space
based on the most efficient
future predicted state.
With no handcrafted rules,
a general purpose learning
framework, and general APIs
to take in sensory input
and produce set point
recommendations,
this platform is
capable to solve
several industrial
optimization problems.
It turns out that
operating a data center
with concrete actions
and measurable rewards
is a great fit for
such a problem.
Modern data centers, especially
the large ones at Google,
are complex pieces of
equipment with billions
of ways of operating them.
For example, suppose we
have a simplified system
with 10 pieces of equipment,
each which has 10 different set
points.
That's already over 3 million
different permutations.
Keep in mind that
a real data center
has much more than 10
pieces of equipment.
They interact with each
other in non-linear manners
while environmental conditions,
such as IT load and weather,
are constantly changing.
Adaptive controls
platform has been helping
reduce energy consumption
in Google data centers
through direct autonomous
control of [INAUDIBLE] systems.
So how does this work?
AI optimizes a reward function.
This could be energy consumption
or any other function expressed
as a mathematical
equation of sensors,
while adapting to the changing
variables like building load,
and still keep meeting
operational constraints
like building comfort.
For example, in the
data center scenario
the AI evaluates millions
of allowable set point
combinations,
predicts future states
of energy consumption and
operational constraints,
removes those that violate
equipment or safety
constraints, chooses
the set points
that maximizes the
objective function,
returns the
recommended set points
into a VMS platform to
be implemented directly
into the equipment.
The generalizability
of this platform
allows a number of industrial
processes and facilities
optimization problems to be
solved using this approach.
Imagine the impact that this
could have on the global energy
use in airports, malls,
corporate buildings,
waste reduction in
chemical plants,
smelters, metal
processing facilities,
all while achieving
higher industrial output.
Another problem space where
we are applying Google's AI
capabilities is industrial
defect detection.
Google's computer
vision capabilities
are consistently rated as
the best in the industry.
We've made these
vision AI capabilities
available through
our general APIs
that use pre-trained machine
learning models trained
on billions of images, and
through AutoML platform, where
you can bring your
own image data
sets to train custom
vision models.
Now we're taking this
one step further.
We are partnering with some
of the largest manufacturers
of the world to bring
high accuracy premium
models for defect
detection, starting
with assembly inspection
and cosmetic inspection,
in an end to end
automated solution.
We've created a dedicated
breakout session
to cover the technical
breakthroughs
of this technology, delivered
by one of my teammates Yinfei.
Please do check it out.
LG has applied our
machine learning models
to achieve 99.9 accuracy for
cosmetic defect detection
in their glass display panels.
Similarly GlobalFoundries
have used our machine
learning models for silicon
vapor defect detection,
achieving 95% accuracy across
hundreds of machine learning
models deployed in
their factories, which
makes for a good segue into
our final topic of scaling AI
at a global industrial scale.
It's one thing running a
pilot on a small subsystem
in a sandbox, and it's a
completely different thing
transforming an entire
industrial workflow
to run autonomously using AI.
Working across multiple
AI products, use cases,
and deployment
environments, we've
honed the approach of
deploying AI at a large scale.
We've come to embrace that the
real world environments are
highly complex, heterogeneous,
unstructured, and fragmented.
This reality has made us design
a deploy anywhere approach
for machine learning.
Our goal is to provide
interoperatability
across all computing platforms,
legacy systems and devices
from cloud, hybrid to edge, from
microcontrollers, CPUs, GPUs,
TPUs, to clusters of
servers, industrial equipment
like high speed
cameras and drones,
and hardware supporting MQTT
and OPC UA industrial standards.
In working with the largest
enterprise customers,
we have seen the challenge
of managing hundreds
of machine learning models
in production environment.
Therefore we developed
managed services
that allow any kind of
machine learning workload,
be it a time series, an image,
or a video machine learning
model, to be deployed on
any kind of edge device.
These services allow
you to version control,
monitor performance,
and retrain models
across a large fleet
of edge devices.
You can learn more about
these deployment platforms
in their dedicated
breakout sessions.
You can also connect with
any of our machine learning
specialists or contact
us through our website
to get started.
Finally, I feel excited
that AI as a discipline
has reached a stage
where it's having
a direct and measurable
impact on scaling
our collective human output.
Our technologies
are truly living up
to their promise of furthering
our progress as a society
and creating a more
promising future.
Thank you once
again for joining,
and I hope you'll enjoy
the other next sessions.
Have a great day.